Seit die Astronauten der Mission Apollo 17
am 19.
Dezember 1972 zurück zur Erde kamen, gab
es keine bemannte Mondlandung mehr.
Trotzdem plant die ESA bis 2030 die erste
Siedlung auf dem Mond mit 6 bis 10 Bewohnern
zu errichten.
Bis 2040 sollen 100 Menschen dort wohnen und
arbeiten, 10 Jahre später bereits 1.000.
Doch ist dies überhaupt möglich?
Gibt es genug Wasser und woher soll der Sauerstoff
kommen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es jeden Tag faszinierende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich willkommen!
Sicher ist zumindest, dass an den Polen des
Mondes tonnenweise Wassereis im Boden lagert.
Die indische Mondsonde Chandrayaan-1 entdeckte
dort vor knapp 10 Jahren mehr als 40 Krater,
die so tief sind, dass das Eis vor der Sonnenstrahlung
geschützt ist.
Inzwischen brachten US-Forscher den Beweis,
dass es sich wirklich um Wasser und kein anderes
gefrorenes Material handelt, das mit Mondgestein
vermischt ist.
Aber auch sonst ist der Mond keineswegs so
staubtrocken wie früher angenommen.
Das Vulkangestein im Mantel des Mondes enthält
ebenfalls Wasser, wobei jedoch weiter unklar
bleibt, woher es stammt.
Damit wäre das Problem des Wassers zumindest
halbwegs vom Tisch, man müsste nur einen
Weg finden das Eis zu schmelzen, um es trinkbar
zu machen.
Schwieriger wird die Gewinnung von Sauerstoff
zum Atmen.
Man könnte das Wasser mittels Elektrolyse
in seine chemischen Bestandteile Sauerstoff
und Wasserstoff spalten, jedoch ist hierbei
die Frage, ob man das wertvolle Trinkwasser
dafür verbrauchen sollte.
Eine bessere Option wäre es, die einzige
Substanz zu verwenden, die auf dem Mond im
Überfluss vorhanden ist: Das Mondgestein
Regolith, das aus sauerstoffhaltigen Mineralien,
sogenannten Oxiden, besteht.
Die Wissenschaftler kennen die Zusammensetzung
von Regolith aus der Untersuchung der Proben,
die in den 1960er und 70er Jahren vom Mond
zur Erde gebracht wurden.
Um Sauerstoff aus diesem Gestein zu gewinnen,
testet die NASA bereits ein System, bei dem
das Gestein von einem kleinen Rover auf eine
Rampe geschoben und zerkleinert wird.
Anschließend wird es von oben in einen Reaktor
gefüllt, der das Gestein zu Sauerstoff verarbeiten
kann.
Dieser Reaktor soll bis zu 660 Kilogramm Sauerstoff
pro Jahr liefern.
Das wäre genug für zwei Astronauten.
Bis jetzt scheint die Chemie in diesem Testreaktor
zu funktionieren, die Techniker haben jedoch
mit anderen Problemen zu kämpfen.
Denn der Mondstaub ist durch den Sonnenwind
elektromagnetisch aufgeladen.
Wenn er aufgewirbelt wird, klebt er überall
und kann durch die geringe Schwerkraft nicht
richtig durch den Trichter rieseln.
Die Techniker versuchen nun, das Regolith
einzusaugen oder den Trichter vibrieren zu
lassen.
Das Regolith könnte weiterhin für den Bau
von Unterkünften auf dem Mond dienen.
Auch hier laufen bereits Tests mit synthetischem
Mondstaub, der dem Original sehr nahe kommt.
Spezialisten des deutschen Luft- und Raumfahrtzentrums
DLR versuchen bereits, aus diesem Staub eine
Art Ziegelstein herzustellen.
Dafür bündeln sie das Sonnenlicht mit 159
Spiegeln und erhitzen damit das Material auf
1.100 Grad, wodurch es anschließend schmilzt
und später beim Abkühlen einen festen Stein
bildet.
So ist zumindest die Idee.
Doch so einfach wie es in der Theorie klingt,
ist es nicht.
Die einzelnen Bestandteile des Materials verhalten
sich in der Hitze sehr unterschiedlich.
Manche Mineralien schmelzen früher, manche
erst später.
Dadurch werden die Steine nicht zu einer gleichmäßigen
Struktur gebacken und zerbrechen dadurch oft
bei Belastung.
Jedoch macht das DLR große Fortschritte und
hat mittlerweile eine sehr solide Rezeptur,
die die Steine halten lässt.
Ob eine Besiedlung des Mondes möglich ist
und wann damit zu rechnen ist, bleibt trotz
allen Fortschritts noch unklar.
Es gilt weitere Faktoren zu beachten wie beispielsweise
die Gewinnung von Nahrung, stark schwankende
Temperaturen mit Temperatursprüngen von mindestens
60 Grad, die Gefahr der kosmischen Strahlung
und nicht zuletzt die geringe Schwerkraft
auf dem Mond, die auf Dauer Probleme bereiten
könnte.
Der Mond hat jedoch noch etwas anderes zu
bieten als eventuellen Lebensraum für uns
Menschen.
Er ist eine große Energiequelle.
Als besonders begehrenswert gilt das Gas Helium-3,
das durch Sonnenwinde zum Mond gelangt ist
und sich im Mondstaub abgelagert hat.
Es gilt als sehr guter Brennstoff.
Nach Berechnungen von Physikern könnte es
auf dem Mond eine Million Tonnen davon geben.
Das wäre genug, um unsere Erde Tausende von
Jahren mit Strom zu versorgen.
Jeff Bezos, der Amazon-Gründer und derzeit
reichster Mensch der Welt, will den Mond mit
seinem Raumfahrt-Unternehmen Blue Origin früher
oder später sogar als Produktionsstandort
nutzen und dort Schwerindustrie ansiedeln,
die mit Sonnenenergie betrieben wird.
Doch es gibt noch eine andere Frage und die
liegt nicht so ganz auf der Hand: Wenn die
Menschheit den Weltraum erobern will, oder
sogar die Erde verlassen muss, würde die
Energie auf der Erde überhaupt ausreichen,
um uns alle in den Weltraum zu bringen?
Eine Frage, die der Kanal Neugierzone in diesem
Video beantwortet.
Dafür, wie immer draufklicken und den kanal
unbedingt abonnieren!
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!